[Musik]
die bären schützt kam im
österreichischen max netz bis zu 300
meter tiefe schluchten das wasser
knietief unter ohrenbetäubendem lärm
doch vor zwei tagen kommt es hier zum
drama zur mittagszeit bei herrlichem
sonnenschein ein schrecklicher knall
mehrere felsstücke lösen sich aus den
steinwänden direkt an der beliebten
wanderroute
sie treffen den wanderweg mehrere
bergsteiger werden von dem steinhagel
überrascht und getroffen eine 50 jahre
alte frau aus ungarn und eine 21 jährige
frau aus österreich sterben acht weitere
wanderer werden verletzt einer von ihnen
schwer
ein großeinsatz für die bergwacht
direktor den wasserfall schreibt ein
rucksack später finden sie darin ein
autoschlüssel der zu diesem auf einem
parkplatz in der nähe abgestellten audi
passt der wagen gehört dem 30-jährigen
parvis kepka ein weiteres opfer des
felssturzes wie wir jetzt wissen in der
nacht wurde seine leiche aus dem wasser
becken gefischt das dritte todesopfer
der bären schützt sie hingegen haben das
glück ihres lebens andreas büchler und
sein zehnjähriger sohn tobias sie
überleben das unglück obwohl die felsen
direkt vor ihnen herabstürzen
binnen sekunden ist dann auch schon
steinlawine fonds losgerollt also das
ist wirklich alles so schnell gegangen
wir haben uns gezeigt hat zum reagieren
ich hab mir dann geschnappt vor mir
hingeben und mit meinen körper versucht
zu schützen
die linke hand nach oben gestreckt und
so wir dann einige steine abfangen
können im krankenwagen
als dann die nachricht kam dass das
junge mädchen was ich zu hütte
mitgetragen habe verstorben ist ein
moment des glücks in der todesopfer in
österreich die drei menschen das leben
kostete und jörg völkerling ist für uns
in österreich jörg es gibt mittlerweile
ein foto das an dem man nachvollziehen
kann
wo und wie die menschen dort zu tode
gekommen sind wenn du uns einmal die
lage beschreiben könnte ist und uns so
das ermittlungsergebnis der behörden
lägen könntest
ich stehe hier am eingang in die klamm
ist es sei nun erstmal ein einstündiger
weg dorthin zurück zu legen da kommt ein
kassenhäuschen
wo man einen kleinen obolus entrichten
muss und etwa wenige hundert meter nach
diesem kassenhäuschen kommt ein erster
foto.de er sehr beliebt bei anderen für
viele instagram fotos wird er gerne her
genommen und da muss dieses schreckliche
unglück passiert sein wir sehen hier die
leiter recht wohl die 21-jährige aus
österreich im begriff wahlleiter
hinaufzusteigen getroffen wurde
etwa in der mitte diese reiter die sich
da entlang der kalkstein wände hoch
zieht war die 50 jährige ungar in die
ins wasser gerissen wurde und noch ein
stück weiter also über dem wasserfall
der darin circa 40 metern höhe in die
tiefe brauchst wurde dann der 30-jährige
pavel chapter getroffen wohl von einem
felsbrocken mit dem wasser in die tiefe
gerissen und diese enorme druck dieses
eiskalten wassers hat ihn dann in dieses
becken was über jahrtausende ausgespült
worden ist wie ein pool hat man mir das
beschrieben wo der hinab gedrückt und
auf seinem körper lag offenbar auch noch
ein schwerer felsbrocken so dass er dann
auch nachdem er nicht vermisst wurde
zunächst am mittwoch nicht entdeckt
werden konnte lediglich einen rucksack
von ihm trieb noch auf der
wasseroberfläche den mann zunächst
fälschlich den anderen opfern zu
geschrieben hatte und erst am gestrigen
abend um 20 uhr haben seine mitbewohner
aus graz wo habe schepker als diplom
ingenieur arbeitete ihn als vermisst
gemeldet und gesagt er war am mittwoch
in dieser klamm unterwegs und daraufhin
es um 20 30 die bergrettung ein
canyoning bergungs drop noch mal
losgezogen
man hat mit starken scheinwerfern dieses
trübe wasser durchleuchtet und gegen 0
uhr 20 gelang es dann tatsächlich auch
mit stangen ihn da aus diesem wasser zu
fischen um ihn dann letztendlich bergen
zu können
ja du hast es erwähnt das ist ein sehr
beliebter ort ein wander ort für
touristen 40.000 besucher kommen dorthin
im jahr
wie konnte es trotzdem zu diesem unglück
kommen man würde denken dass es alles
abgesichert wird kontrolliert wenn da so
viele menschen jedes jahr durch kommen
also selbst der alpenverein sagt das ist
ein sehr ungewöhnliches geschehen was
hier passiert ist und er sagt auch
solche klammern sind eigentlich die
sichersten orte im gelände
denn sie werden so stark überwacht wie
sonst eigentlich keine wege in normalen
gebirge
auch hier war es so dass immer vor der
saison die sich corona verzögert hat die
bergrettung durchgegangen ist die steine
die bände auf lose felsbrocken überprüft
hat es war nichts zu beanstanden
dann gab es aber wohl in der nacht auf
dienstag ein starkes gewitter und man
sagt es könnte einer der auslöser
gewesen sein dass ich da dieser facebook
durch verwitterung gelöst hat und in die
tiefe gestürzt ist